if you've ever driven a car you're gay
that's right you're gay you might be
married to someone of the opposite sex
you may never have done anything gay so
to speak but you're pretty gay you're a
big homo they want you to be gay and
they're going to make you gay through
their advertising
[Music]
I don't have a problem if you're gay not
a problem my husband's gay not a big
deal to me but uh you know I don't know
that every advertisement on television
has to be uh promoting the homos what
gay person is walking in when you want
to buy a car and you know okay so you're
sitting there you're looking at two
trucks well which one of these trucks is
there is this what is this truck do you
do you have this in Rainbow it's just
none of it makes any sense but they keep
bludgeoning us over the head with this
nonsense